I like this without the desk it's nicer
without that I I'm enjoying it too it
feels I used to really feel like I was
doing people's taxes for them well now
and so we just thought like let's lose
the desk I don't need that
and then it's tradition of course yeah I
did that for 25 years you know you do
something for 25 years I've never done
anything for 25 years yeah but that desk
you know on all these shows isn't the
desk a phony desk
yes it's when you go behind it you've
probably never seen or imagined this
when you go behind it it's like there's
nothing also wood there's no drawers
there's no papers back there everybody
has the same thing I just did Colbert
show last night and I look behind at one
point I look behind his guest and it was
completely empty and it was just like my
desk used to be completely empty one
thing of tissues and a thing of Purell
yeah that's it that's a puke bucket
there's always a puke bucket back there
Jan some pornography yeah I want to
compliment you on your your style every
time you come on the show you're dressed
in a very different look you're not
afraid to take risks with clothing is
that true how one might say yes yes yes
that might be true well you as well
you're in a new chapter you've you've
blossomed like a like a flower a flower
like a like a like a depression-era
gas station attendant yeah like a
zucchini blossom what's zucchini blossom
what what's the zucchini blossom it's a
vegetable
yeah but they serve it now as a starter
it's kind of a flash fried and it's got
some cheese in it doesn't it yeah what
is wrong with you right now I love it
when you make you know my favorite thing
that you do that no other human I've met
in showbiz says you make little noises
sometimes and sometimes and he does it
we tell you he does it in real life I've
run into you out in the real world and
you'll I'll see you and I'll go hide if
you have you have I would say many many
orgasms yeah not so many
you can't imagine what I'm feeling right
now but I do like that you you think
shoes are important well I do I always I
always have I mean I was always
interested in clothes and then when I
started to study acting seriously you
know I um realized that you know you
could work from the inside out also from
the outside in and so with a shoe you
wear and the everything you wear has
something to do with how you might feel
and what the solution to this particular
character was in any case also me when I
go out I play jazz you know and so I
have to go out and dress up for one
thing or another but yes shoes even in
my own life
the feeling of shoes and shoes and all
sorts of things about shoes yeah but I
like shoes and it makes a big difference
yep I'm particular about my shoes how do
I get you out of this loop cover the
feet and shoes are most important shoes
of course yes but shoes shoes shoes are
everywhere shoes are here in shoes are
there shoes maybe someday in my hair
shoes but you know what I am like Rain
Man it's true but let's look at your
shoes all right and then let's look at
my shoes in all of our shoes Wow
back in the loop okay
it's a simple shoe well it is a simple
shoe has a leather lace I see yeah as do
i yes hmm see the noises he makes these
hmm and of course a nice grippy I'm sure
you're sensitive this a nice grippy
bottom which is my nickname for you
anyway